HBO's Watchmen forges its own path, but it
also doesn't forget where it came from.
It's packed full of covert references throughout
its first season - so if you're curious, here
are some of the Easter eggs you might have
missed.
In what might be a meta-joke about Easter
eggs, Watchmen features a ton of actual eggs.
"Which came first, the chicken or the egg?
The answer appears to be both."
Some serve as references to the comic series.
For example, in the first episode, as Angela
Abar breaks up egg yolks in a bowl, they form
the smiley face you might recognize from the
cover of the first issue of Watchmen.
There are plenty of other eggs throughout
the season that are more generally symbolic.
Dr. Manhattan conjures and drinks one during
his first date with Angela.
In the fourth episode, we see a couple that
gets some much-needed fertility help from
the mysterious Lady Trieu spilling eggs on
their porch.
And during the series finale, Angela finds
one egg left unbroken among the others she
smashed to the ground earlier in the evening.
Dr. Manhattan left that egg behind after his
death as a way of transferring his powers.
Angela consumes the egg, but whether she has
his powers is left ambiguous.
Let's jump back to the smiley face image:
Naturally, show creator Damon Lindelof and
his crew found other ways to work the iconic
visual into the show, particularly the blood
spatter on the Comedian's yellow button.
The first episode of Watchmen opens on a horrific
depiction of the Tulsa Race Riot of 1921,
which remains one of the most devastating
instances of racial violence in U.S. history.
White citizens attacked Greenwood, a primarily
African-American neighborhood, looting, robbing,
and killing with abandon.
In Watchmen's universe, descendants of the
attack were paid reparations, causing resentment
among white supremacists.
In that sequence, the show sneaks in a terrible,
tragic reminder of the button - a blood spatter
on the head of young Will Reeves that perfectly
mimics the smiley face.
A similar blood splatter can be spotted later
in the same episode, on Judd's badge during
his hanging.
Watchmen takes place in a world quite different
from ours, where Nixon never resigned and
Robert Redford was the president that followed
him.
A lot is different culturally, too, including
the popular reading material.
Max Shea's pirate yarn Tales of the Black
Freighter is prominently featured and excerpted
in the original comic.
That explains why there are so many references
to pirates in the show, specifically, a detective
named Pirate Jenny, a costume donned by one
of Angela's children, a skull-and-crossbones
wax seal on a game warden's letter, a pirate
flag, the name of Laurie's hotel, and more.
Several characters are also spotted reading
a book called Fogdancing in quick blink-and-you'll-miss-it
shots, another novel written by the prolific,
fictional Shea.
Seems like it's pretty good, too.
"Would you like me to get you another book?
"No, I like this one.”
When a young Angela looks at a series of VHS
tapes in the show's seventh episode, one of
them is a Hollywood adaptation of Fogdancing.
Both versions of Nite Owl were major characters
in the Watchmen comic, but his story doesn't
get much play in the show.
The show is, however, rife with actual owls
and references to the nocturnal birds.
Laurie even has a pet owl.
"What's his name?"
"Who."
"The owl."
"Who.
That's his name.
Ask him yourself."
Angela's other daughter dresses as an owl,
and the kids also have a few owl toys visible
on their dresser.
Plus, when Angela dons night-vision goggles,
she looks eerily like Nite Owl himself.
The first Nite Owl's famous tell-all book,
Under the Hood, also makes a cameo.
In the first episode, a copy of the book is
on doomed Sheriff Judd Nelson's desk when
Angela stops by his office, and during their
subsequent chat, she sips coffee from an owl-shaped
mug.
One of the big questions in the early episodes
of the season was where Dr. Manhattan was
hiding.
Was he on Mars as widely believed?
Or somewhere else?
As it turned out, he was hiding in plain sight
as Cal Abar, supportive, loving husband to
Angela.
After the two fell in love, Dr. Manhattan
took on the appearance of a regular human
and had Angela wipe his memory so he could
live as normal a life as possible, at least
for a while.
There are plenty of clues leading up to Cal's
big reveal.
Other characters are skeptical about Cal's
"accident" that left him with amnesia.
"It was a car crash, right?
I've done a lot of research on memory.
Total amnesia's extremely rare."
And he and Laurie, a former lover of Dr. Manhattan,
seem to have a special connection right off
the bat.
In the eighth episode, we learn how he and
Angela met.
Two very specific musical cues accompany Dr.
Manhattan throughout the episode: "Mr. Blue"
by The Fleetwoods and a riff on George Gershwin's
"Rhapsody in Blue."
In the Watchmen universe, the U.S. wins the
Vietnam War decisively thanks to Dr. Manhattan's
help, and President Richard Nixon is exalted
as a hero.
Vietnam becomes the 51st state, and Nixon
is remembered as an American icon.
Throughout the series, Vietnam's inclusion
in the United States is addressed rather broadly.
Angela grows up there, and Saigon is mentioned
repeatedly as an American city.
During Judd Crawford's funeral, the flag draped
over his coffin looks very different from
the real flag, and it bears 51 stars.
During the show's pilot, when Looking Glass
interrogates a suspect inside a mysterious
chamber that shows alternating patriotic and
disturbing images, Nixon's face can be seen
on a revised Mount Rushmore.
The bar in Saigon where Angela and Dr. Manhattan
first meet is called Mr. Eddy's Bar, a direct
reference to the comics and the site of one
of its most horrific events.
Eddie Blake, also known as the Comedian, took
up with a Vietnamese woman during the war,
but when she became pregnant, he lost interest
in her.
After the unnamed woman slashed Blake's face
with a beer bottle, leaving a scar, he shot
her in the face at Mr. Eddy's and killed her.
The director of the episode, Nicole Kassell,
told Polygon that the show's production crew
used descriptions from the comic to inform
what the interior of Mr. Eddy's would look
like.
Dr. Manhattan explains towards the end of
the season that everything that will happen
has either already occurred or is happening
right now, making every outcome inevitable.
He's also notably the son of a watchmaker.
As such, there's a clock motif that runs through
Watchmen, connecting Dr. Manhattan's thought
process and wisdom to Adrian Veidt.
Veidt, who spends years imprisoned on Europa
with cloned servants created by Dr. Manhattan
as his only company, writes a play for the
clones to perform called The Watchmaker's
Son.
It's a retelling of Dr. Manhattan's origin
story, though it burns one of the clones to
death rather than giving him superpowers.
Beyond that, there are plenty of clocks in
the show, all of which reference the comics'
Doomsday Clock as well as its final cover,
which itself depicts a bloody clock.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.